aeropuerto de kabul 31 de agosto de 2021
después de varias horas la ciudad se ha
convertido oficialmente en la capital
del autodenominado emirato islámico de
afganistán los talibanes han ganado la
guerra al hacerse con el control del
último santuario controlado por el
ejército de eeuu después de 20 largos
años de presencia en el país cuando
lario juego le dije esto me hace feliz
el regreso de la disciplina islámica el
sistema de los no creyentes que nos
invadieron terminó intentaban imponer
una república democrática y dijeron que
iban a establecer un sistema de
gobernanza y de desarrollo económico
pero miren no nos han dejado nada lo han
destruido todos
la pista parece abandonada
hace solo 24 horas era el escenario de
uno de los puentes aéreos más
importantes de la historia
esta es la herencia estadounidense
nuestros líderes firmaron un acuerdo con
ellos nos respetaron su palabra pero
nosotros sí
así que los hemos dejado ir
y
las tropas estadounidenses se retiraron
del país hace unas horas y dejaron miles
de vehículos
dejaron estos helicópteros que se pueden
ver a mi alrededor abandonados y los
talibanes están entrando y básicamente
están revisando que tienen y con que
cuentan es una situación increíble
bastante surrealista
para los nuevos dueños del país todo
está por hacer y la amenaza de sus
rivales del grupo estado islámico pesa
sobre afganistán
creemos y esperamos que la retirada de
los estadounidenses de afganistán pondrá
fin a los proyectos del grupo estado
islámico
harding esperamos dejar de ser testigos
de esta inseguridad y de esta situación
los soldados estadounidenses no se
fueron sin sabotear todo lo que no se
pudieron llevar
pero los talibanes están confiados como
este nuevo jefe autoproclamado del
aeropuerto que acaba de llegar
el emirato islámico de afganistán tiene
empleados y material profesional
afortunadamente tenemos todos los
recursos que necesitamos confiamos en
poder poner en marcha los aviones
los talibanes ya están al mando pero al
mando de un país al borde del colapso
tras años de guerra y sacrificios
afganistán todavía le esperan miles de
desafíos